now what's great about cosine is that
because if you understand that color
means compliment right side theta cos
theta the close graph is just the sine
graph but it's been moved over it's been
shifted horizontally by 90 degrees right
that's that's the only difference
okay but just to confirm it let's go
back to the unit circle right zero
degrees
what's cause of zero what's the
coordinates here one zero so therefore
cos of 0 is 1 right as I move around the
circle cause of 90 degrees the x
coordinate is zero so close of 90 is
zero okay and then I can keep going
around cause of 180 comes down to
negative one cause of 270 crosses
through zero again and cause all 360 I'm
back to the stop so I have exactly the
same shape but it's being shifted 90
degrees
okay exactly the same shape just for the
sake of it if you have another color
there you might like to draw like a dog
legs or something you might like to draw
sign over the top of cosign like it
looks like this okay and you can
literally see you can see the shift that
you can see how what is the complement
of the other it's just being moved every
point moved forward or backwards
depending on your point of view 90
degrees okay I've got the positive
values of clear side I'm going to
complete it with the negative edge I'm
going to draw a tan of my third set of
axes here now you will notice I've
already defiled my beautiful clean
Cartesian plane with all of these dots
on them why didn't I do that
what are the green nuts one of the green
dots the green dots si which makes the
blue dots cosine pause right okay now
why am I put siding cause onto this
graph yes very good
so the definition of tan is itself
dependent on the other two functions
okay now you can think about that in
ratios but now we're graphing now okay
so what I'm gonna do is try and visually
do the ratios between these two things
there are some bits to do that are
easier here than others so I'm gonna
start with what's obvious okay all by
denominator I have cos theta
but denominator is cos theta okay now
when you see a graph like say I was put
in here we see a graph like this Wieck
was one of those right and it has a
denominator and there's actually
something happening underneath there
rather than say like this X onto that
has a denominator we don't care there's
not
nothing interesting happen even
denominator up this you automatically
lock in and say haha that excellent
denominator means that what does it mean
X Club is Europe I have our restrictions
right off the bat okay now visually what
that means it is what that restriction
over here means is an asset turn on my
graph and we know what this looks like
it's got that X equal zero asymptote
this also has asymptotes when its
denominators equal to 0 and I have drawn
the denominator on there for you
as a blue dotted line okay so for
instance see this here what X values
that think this is cause we're close
equal to zero the first place we're
close equal to zero is 90
but if Clause of 90s put into this I get
zero the denominator and it breaks
so in fact x equals mighty is a vertical
asymptote so I'm gonna put it right way
vertical asked okay because it's an
asymptote it's off the axis I'm better
label what its equation is it's x equals
90 degrees now that's not the only
acetone on there in fact I have
infinitely many asymptotes on the
tangrams okay cuz every time cosine goes
to the origin sorry it goes to the axis
every time it makes an asymptote for
tank okay somebody draw all of them on
my diagram in my domain I have four of
them okay now I know my graph is signed
to get a little bit busy and I haven't
drawn anything on it yet so if I were
doing this on paper I would do those
dotted lines I'd do them in light pencil
and then afterwards don't rub them away
right but this is just for the sake of
illustration it's okay if you have it
it's fine all right now let's have a
look again after I put my asymptotes
here which are nice concrete I know
what's gonna happen there
there's another small set of points that
I also can very quickly define right
when the denominator zero BAM it breaks
what about when the d-brane is zero when
the numerator is zero the whole thing is
zero right because you're a divided by 1
is zero zero divided by 4000 divided by
a rockmelon is probably zero but at the
moment undefined today guard zero
divided by anything so my numerator I
have colored in green right so
everywhere my numerator passes through
the axis table posture the actors does
that make sense
so I've got pasta through the XS there
and they're there on my graph within my
domain I have five times alright we're
almost ready okay now keep in mind by
the way that because sine is a repeating
shape it's a periodic graph and cosine
is also periodic right when you combine
them your result is surprise surprise
also periodic okay so really all I need
to do is get one section of this graph
and then I can just copy it just like I
got this section and I just copied it
and I took this section and I just so
I'm gonna focus on the middle of the
graph here what's happening here around
the y-axis all right I'm going to start
at the origin now what's happening to
this graph as I approached the asymptote
now for starters right think back to
when we were graphing rational functions
that I talked to through graphing this
right my numerator is positive my
denominator is positive so what do you
expect the total things scientific it
will also be positive so up here this is
what's happening right now which
direction is it going and well look my
numerator is getting bigger and my
denominator is getting smaller
in fact my denominator is getting very
very small okay so when you have a very
small denominator what happens to the
whole number it gets huge right because
if you take a number and you divide it
by something and then you divide it by
something smaller and something smaller
and said try the whole thing exploits
okay so therefore this thing is going up
it's doing this and it's approaching yes
attack what's happening on the left-hand
side
okay because I've got a denominator this
is positive but I have a numerator
that's negative right I'm gonna be down
here in negative but just like before my
denominator excuse me is approaching
zero right so I'm Skye rocky to enormous
numbers it's just that they're enormous
negative numbers so I have this kind of
symmetry it kind of looks like a cubic
mile I'm going to point out some
differences in a second okay there's the
shape now I can go and repeat that
process all the way through but again
referring to the fact that this guy
finds what we call periodicity
it's a periodic okay I just get taking a
graphical school copy let's notice a few
things about this thing okay for
starters who started it does look a
whole lot like the y equals x cubed
graph it does look a lot like that but
there is one crucial difference and it's
the same difference that I pointed out
when we were talking about this right
see how sine x as it passes through the
axis Chiappa here and here right it has
a gradient it doesn't go vertical okay
neither kind of obviously in this case
neither does it go horizontal and that's
what X cube does X cube does this it
approaches the origin slows down and
then it rises off okay so what you got
there if you're watching for a tangent
in fact I have drawn attention it's the
x axis okay now if I were to come over
here it just so happens in an
interesting sequence of events that we
can explore the later on that this
creating here of tan X at the origin it
matches exactly the gradient here of
sine X it's one why is that we'll
explore that in due time okay but the
important thing is that number one it's
not zero okay it shouldn't be horizontal
there like X cubed ish okay and just
like here it's not well it has a
gradient it was very cool it's not a
great infinity it just doesn't have the
gravy because there's there run to
divide by
secondly you'll notice I've got area it
just keeps going right where is sine and
cosine I'll walked in in this range okay
what's the range of this function
remember range is a statement about
vertical where I can go vertically so I
can have any real value any real value
okay X on the other hand all real values
of X here all real values of X here but
this has a whole series of holes in it
okay
everywhere cosine is negative you have a
home in town okay one more thing to
mention before you on to these last
three graphs and they're going to go in
quick succession okay I talked about the
periodicity right of these guys that
they periodically repeat okay we call
the period of a graph how long a section
is before it repeats right so how long
does it go before it repeats and the
answer is it goes 360 degrees after you
pass through 360 you're back to where
you started
no matter where you start suppose I
started down here right I've got 90 180
270 360 I'm at the same spot I was
before I have just another different
copy but 360 degrees what about cosine
also 360 now interestingly when you put
together a function whose period is 360
with another function whose period 360
you get a different function whose
period is hundred eighty huh
wonder why that is there's something
kind intuitive about that but it's quite
obviously true okay so every 180 degrees
you've got a new copy of the weather